if we're lending money that ostensibly
we don't have to kids who really have no
hope of paying it back in order to train
them for jobs they clearly don't exist I
might suggest that you know we've gone
around the bend a little bit hi I'm Nick
Gillespie for recent TV and this is the
first time I think that we've ever
interviewed a bonafide opera singer at
reason TV on camera and today we're
talking with Mike Rowe who's better
known as the longtime host of Discovery
Channel's popular show dirty jobs for
which Rowe who won sang bit parts for
the Baltimore Opera and worked as an
on-air pitchman for QVC takes on gigs
straight out of Bob Dylan songs working
on fishing boats sewer systems oil
derricks slaughterhouses you name it
his passion these days is drawing
attention to what he sees as a dangerous
disconnect between the work that he says
needs to be done in America on a
physical blue-collar level and the way
that all aspects of American society
seems to demonize and push people away
from the sort of dirty jobs that don't
require a college degree anymore through
the micro foundation and profoundly
disconnected a venture between Rowe and
the heavy equipment manufacturer
Caterpillar Rowe is talking a lot these
days about what he calls the diploma
dilemma we've got millions unemployed
and millions of jobs that are going
unfilled Mike Rowe welcome to Reason TV
thanks takes you right that I did it's
good
I only stumbled on it a bit not bad I
mean the delivery was good he accuracy
I'd put it about 90 95 percent and
that's a lot coming from you so let's
start with talking about what you see as
the real problem that's cropped up over
the past 40 years or so in America we're
doing everything we can to push every
kid to go to a four-year college what's
wrong with that so that's not working I
mean you got a trillion dollars in debt
on the student loan side you have a
skills gap something talked about what
what do you mean a skills gap
well you have right now about three
million jobs transportation commerce
trades that can't be filled and this is
stuff anything from carpentry to
electric of being electrician plumbers
heating and strong electric you know
there's a holy truck driver you know
there's a long welders eggwin
jobs that typically parents don't sit
down and say to their kids
if all goes well this is this is what
you're going to do but these are
actually also jobs I mean not only are
they available but they are also they
pay well listen yes is the short answer
but of course you know pay well it's
kind of relative right what they what
they are mostly in my opinion are
opportunities you know a good welder
right now can pretty much write his or
her own ticket companies like
caterpillar Bechtel you can go down the
list they have had open shortages for
decades and so you know I talked to a
kid the other day up in Butler North
Dakota
so it's Butler right it's cold but he
works on heavy equipment up there and
over 100 bucks an hour work when he
wants paid for his house in cash raising
a family no debt people don't tell his
story so so that's part of the problem
is that instead we're telling everybody
you know just you got to get that
sheepskin you got to get the college ba
otherwise you're not going to be happy
you're not going to have any opportunity
it feels that way to me yeah I mean
that's that was my experience in high
school and I still hear the same
platitudes today talk a bit about that
because you have a great story about how
you were in your high school guidance
counselor's office and you saw a sign
that said work smart not hard mr. Dunbar
yeah well he he called me down as I
guess you know millions of kids have
been called down to talk about my future
and he was looking at some test scores
and said look you you're not an idiot
you know you got a shot at James Madison
University of Maryland maybe some other
schools here's here's what I would
suggest and I said you know I I don't
have any money but more importantly I
don't I don't have any idea what I want
to do so while I figure that out
you know I thought I'd go to a community
college at which point he says well
that's way below your potential and
pointed to the poster that said work
smart not hard the thing about the
poster wasn't just the bromide at the
bottom it was the image on left hand
side you've got a college graduate
recently matriculated cap and gown
Sun setting behind him looking like he
owns the world in the future and next to
him is a mechanic holding a wrench
covered in grease or something worse
looking down at the ground like he won
the vocational consolation prize of all
time and you know that was a very
specific
campaign for college for higher
education and we're talking this is what
like late 70s are 70 nice yeah yeah but
like all PR campaigns and most
everything I'm doing right now really is
through the lens of a kind of marketing
proposition but all PR campaigns always
go too far and they always it seems
promote the thing they want to focus on
at the expense of something else now
it's kind of egregious in education in
my opinion but it shouldn't be shocking
because look the best way to sell a
truck is to talk about how lousy the
competitor the best way to get elected
is to talk about how creepy your
opponent is and the best way to really
promote college hard is to talk about
how subordinate all the other
opportunities and and you've replaced
work smart not hard with work smart and
hard was what's the difference well a
very small of is it a conjunction yes
and is that what it is all right so yeah
we at the time I thought you know if I
had any balls at all I'd reach across
mr. Dunbar's office with a magic marker
and cross out knot and scratch in and my
grandfather would have approved that I
didn't do it because my father would
have disapproved but years later I've
done it and now as part of our
fundraising our ongoing dirty campaign
for the trades we sell posters that say
work smart and hard I now play the role
of the Graduate standing there holding
my degree looking somewhat confused by
the industrial setting in which I find
myself next to a far more aspirational
tradesman right so it's just another way
to juxtapose what uh what are the goals
of the work smart and hard campaign okay
you know what what are you hoping to
effect well in a really general way a
conversation exactly like the one we're
having and a question precisely like the
one you just posed because if you don't
talk about it the whole thing is forget
it you know we we have to change the
conversation and we have to challenge
the existing protocol if you will so the
first thing is this general PR campaign
around the trades the second thing there
is a financial component to it I mean
the posters are only ten bucks but if I
can get twenty or thirty thousand of
hanging in guidance counselor's office
around the around the country right now
well that's fun
and we take the money we raise of course
and it goes into a into a foundation to
keep the conversation going and to award
what we call work ethic scholarships
what is a work ethic scholarship the
scholarship program and the scholarship
business as I understand it right now
rewards for basic things intelligence we
have academic scholarships athleticism
if you can hit a three-pointer we have
money for you for days talent right I
mean we we reward talent we reward
athleticism we reward intelligence and
of course need you need based
scholarships and those are the
categories that most scholarships
address to some degree or another whose
addressing work ethic whose affirmative
ly trying to reward the behavior we want
to encourage the behavior that the micro
works wants to at least talk about
really renounce to two things the
willingness to learn a useful skill and
the willingness to work your ass off
combined we think that is something that
ought to be affirmative ly rewarded
where did that go wrong or when did that
disappear the idea that you know you
should learn a skill that is actually
useful or in need and that you should
work hard or I don't know you know I
think that's that's a good question for
a real social anthropologist my own
opinion is just that there's a kind of
inertia the most parents would agree
exists and it's the desire to see
something better for your kids than you
had the question of course is what is
better you know is it better right now
today to have 140,000 in debt but a
degree from Georgetown and law or is it
better to be that kid I described up in
Butler look Marion I don't know right
but there is an inertia that says the
first one is better than let's talk a
little bit about the college loan scam I
mean because partly I mean you talk
about okay there's a trillion dollars in
debt most of that will be
I mean it's subsidized by taxpayers but
most of the principal will be paid off
by the people who take the loans but
you're against the idea of
taxpayer supported loans going to
college right well look it's a it we
hold a note right so it's whether I'm
against it or not I I get I get a little
curious about it when it gets to a
trillion dollars so if we're lending
money that ostensibly we don't have to
kids who really have no hope of paying
it back in order to train them for jobs
they clearly don't exist I might suggest
that you know we've gone around the bend
a little bit and our clearly pumping
that extra money into the system allows
colleges to raise their prices I mean of
course know the cost of a degree and
this I do know because I've read it in
several reputable sources has increased
over five hundred times the rate of
inflation since the mid 80s five hundred
times the rate of inflation nothing else
comes close not even health care health
care is like two fifty to sixty so this
this thing is an outlier this thing that
the cost of this thing has increased so
exponentially I can't believe it's not
daily headline news imagine any other
commodity increasing at that rate and
think for a minute to you know I get it
education is hugely important that if
there's if there's only one thing that's
more important in education
maybe maybe health and fitness right
because what's the point if you're not
functioning but imagine the conversation
we have about colleges today applied to
gyms mmm-hmm right imagine saying okay
it's important to be healthy and fit so
what you need to do is spend a thousand
dollars a month at the most expensive
club in town otherwise your heart might
explode you'll crap your pants you'll
get fat and nobody will love you okay
meanwhile there's why yeah obviously
you've got some background research on
me so I didn't want to say anything but
there's a there's an odor there is no
but you're not anti college not at all
yeah so so explain that okay so auntie
debt in the same way I'm not anti gym
membership look if you if you got a
thousand bucks a month and you can go to
the place with the shiny equipment and
the cadre of personal trainers and the
and the and the private Jacuzzi do it
and and enjoy your protein shake in the
privacy of your own largess right not
your large ass your large s but if you
can accomplish the same thing for 12
bucks a month you know then I think it
would be prudent to at least put them on
the table and if I have to pay for part
of your membership in either facility
then I might get a little exercised
about your ultimate choice if you can't
pay it back what are the roots of the
kind of demon demonization or D
prioritization of blue-collar work or of
dirty jobs
I think it's fear you know I mean you've
got kids right yeah so it's got to be
very scary to not have a really specific
answer to questions like what's the best
path that we know and and to have
somebody tell you in a fairly convincing
way that there is an answer to that
question that must be very comforting
and it must be very comforting to pass
that certainty on to your on to your kid
to here's here's what you need to do you
need to work hard in school you need to
study that that it's not bad advice it's
just that like I said before it always
goes too far because rather than put a
period after work hard and study hard we
put an ellipses and that's followed by
or else you're going to wind up working
down at the construction thing anyway
well that you you come from a background
of your grandfather was a laborer I mean
he worked with his hands he built things
did he say to you you know I want you to
do exactly what I did or does he watch
it you know I want you to have a job I
mean would you hear this all the time
well you don't have to wash your hands
for 45 minutes when you come home before
you can have dinner he was he was fairly
agnostic about my hopes and dreams I
wasn't I very specifically wanted to
follow in his footsteps the guy could
build a house without a blueprint he
only went to the eighth grade but by the
time he was in his 30s he was a master
electrician carpenter steam fitter pike
and you talk you've talked about how one
of your the best days you've ever had
was kind of where you first learned the
pleasures of dirty work when I
tell us about that I was I was maybe 10
or 11 we had a we lived in a small
little farmhouse and we had one toilet
and I went down one morning took care of
business and stood up to flush it for
whatever reason I liked to watch it go
away
was something satisfying about watching
something was just in me going away you
know and on this particular morning it
went away and then the toilet made a
sound
you know kind of like the like that pig
noise in the Amityville Horror just a
gurgling you know a demonic sort of
disappointing screech and everything
that had just been in me literally came
flying backwards and it covered me and
so my grandfather lived next door
obviously something between the septic
tank and the toilet had gone tragically
wrong and my grandfather being a
magician of sorts dug up the yard in
just the right place found the problem
in the pipe replaced the pipe there was
welding there was laughing there was
cursing my mother brought me my first
thermos of coffee my dad and my
grandfather and I worked covered in crap
for most of the day I took the day off
school to do it was a very satisfying
day because I was I was with the two
most important men in my life and and I
saw again certainly not for the first or
the last time a problem eel problem
corrected and it just made a lot of
chronological sense to my brain I wanted
to do that the gene that my grandfather
had cruelly and horribly skipped right
over me right and I washed out of every
shop class there was in high school and
it was my grandfather who ultimately
said look you ought to think about
getting a different toolbox so he was
like sorry kid you don't have the chops
to become a master electrician go into
TV no he didn't go that far but what he
said was it doesn't matter what you do
you think you want to do what I can do
what you want to do is work in the way
I'm working so in other words whether
you're a TV interviewer or an opera
singer or a writer you can approach your
craft like a tradesman and by that I
mean like a freelancer instead of okay I
need my job and my job will be 30 years
and will come with benefit
it's and it will be provided blah blah
blah that that's not working anymore and
I was never really enamored of it I
liked the idea of the the classic
freelancer I always have but you know
where the word came from by the way tell
me I'm going to neck are you ready okay
it's actually I am already sitting down
so no I love the jacket be that I said
that see because I [ __ ] 101 when I put
my hat on I'm like people that over I am
without my hat they probably don't
overview over I I get that a lot yes so
in in the olden times a freelancer was a
knight who served no Lord he was just
the he had his horse and he had his
lance and his lance wasn't free it was
to the highest bedroom is a very
mercenary way to look at the world but
it's a great way to sort of step back
and protect your margins in these times
in my opinion well talk a little bit
about them what are the what are the
ways that you create or develop a
stronger work ethic and people because I
agree with you that apart from the skill
set you know which is important and that
will always change and certainly the
things that our parents or grandparents
knew for sure we're going to be the you
know it's plastics or its computer
whatever you know you never know but the
one thing that you can know is that if
you can adapt your skills to a changing
world you're in good shape and if you
work hard how do you how do you create
or how do you instill better work ethics
and B I think it has something to do
with being suspicious of anything it's
too easy
being suspicious of anything that
doesn't hurt a little bit you know it
has something to do with the willingness
to to find and take the reverse commute
it's a big lesson on dirty jobs you know
there's a there's another bromide
another platitude out there that always
kind of chop my ass a little bit which
is follow your passion you know my
Scoutmaster
by my reverend my dad liked everybody
grown-ups like son just just follow your
passion it's terrible advice you know on
dirty jobs I met a lot of very
passionate people but very few of them
followed their passion into their
current vocation les Swanson from
Wisconsin clean septic tanks you know I
asked him one day
Oh fine I mean we're literally standing
up to we're up to our nipples in the
most indescribable bully abase on the
planet around I said less will you would
you do before this you know it's like
110 the sweats running off his face he
looks at me and he says I swear I was a
guidance counselor he was a he was a
psychiatrist a psychologist and I said
why'd you why'd you leave that and
without missing a beat he said I got
tired of dealing with other people [ __ ]
is very funny but it was also it was it
was very instructive because he he
always thought that what he wanted to do
was the thing he was told he should do
he became passionate about something he
really he really didn't care for when it
came time to make the change he just
looked around to see where everybody was
going and he went the other way took him
into a septic tank own business a couple
of workers very happy so if you're
really asking how do you know that
you're going in the right direction how
do you really foster a good work ethic I
think I think you just have to identify
the thing that most people don't want to
do figure out a way to do it and then
figure out a way to love it
what should schools be more in the
business of doing vote tech stuff I mean
there's a long tradition of you know and
this is something that I think people
are worried about when they look at a
European system of Education where they
say hey you know what by the time Timmy
is 12 and we've done a couple of
aptitude tests we know this guy isn't
you know he's not college material so
let's make him an auto mechanic you know
so you know there's that level that I
think people rightly push back against
but there's also the question of you
know when you were talking about a
freelance is there anything less than a
freelance system than the public school
system that most people grow up in where
you seem to have a lot of time service I
mean a lot of good teachers but also
it's kind of like I got 30 years and out
all right so we're you know should it be
businesses that are actually doing
apprenticeships and that are building up
in interest and saying look you know we
can offer you a good job at a good wage
with you know some honor and integrity I
would I mean if I had a big business I
would do that I don't know that they
should do it you know I don't want to
shoot all over anybody but I I think
that
you know if I if I depended on a skilled
workforce then I would not depend on a
public education system to provide it
for me I would set up my own things
internally and I would make sure that I
was doing things in the most effective
way I could in terms of training the
best candidate I could find but I do
think that the companies are at a kind
of disadvantage because so many kids who
come to apply for the kinds of work
we're talking about they have an
expectation it's not realistic they've
been watching American Idol for too long
they just have an idea that look I did
my time in high school maybe I even did
my time in college so where's where's my
cheese okay why you want me to do what
so there's a there's a real disconnect
in the way we educate visa vie the
opportunities that are available there's
a disconnect between the companies that
are providing the opportunities and the
parents and guidance counsellors who are
advising our kids and yeah in the end I
mean that's a long answer to your
question but ultimately the company is
going to have to step in to provide the
training that ultimately is well and you
I mean this goes to you're a critic of
kind of credentialism the idea that you
know you can you jump through enough
hoops and then you get the cheese or
whatever and you you have your own
business and you've talked about how
difficult it is to hire people it's a
nightmare yeah we'll talk about that
well you know why can't you why isn't it
an easy thing to just figure out you
know because I can't ask you can't ask
people the questions everybody would
want to ask if they had to hire you you
just can't sit down and say okay scale
of one to ten where do you fall on the
[ __ ] meter you know be honest what
are you an [ __ ] it'd be good to know
yeah and if you are look thanks for
coming by but we you know we we already
have we have all the answers but we
don't have any oh we don't need another
know we were thinking you know you know
most but you really you don't need more
than what technically we each have we
have two sphincters right one here and
went and looked at clinically they're
identical that's right I mean there's no
way to know up from them so how do you
how do you get around that though how do
you get around or do do you see is there
move away it kind of in a world where
everybody goes to high school every or
everybody graduates high school
everybody graduates college it seems do
we fall back into a new way of figuring
out who's who's a good worker how do we
tell who's good and who's bad I don't
think we do you know look you said it
before it's it's it's one of the reasons
we fall in love with credentialing it's
the same reason we fall in love with
saying one-size-fits-all with education
look it's simple all you have to do is
go to college look and simply either
have your credentials or you don't I was
at the Marine Corps ball a couple of
weeks ago I go every year I talked to a
medic cookie can't find work now eight
months earlier he's somewhere over there
he's got his service revolver in one
hand he's holding the femur or the
femoral artery shot you know he's saving
a life he's taking a life pretty much it
the guys qualified okay but he's not
credentialed you know he can't get
higher as a nurse right now can't do it
so the credentialing system you know all
the C words get tricky right compliance
you know the hidden costs of compliance
in the work industry today is is
staggering what do you what do you mean
by that I mean that you know the cost of
hiring somebody is not simply the cost
of paying them their salary and on dirty
jobs certainly you you see I've talked
to so many employers in every state and
after we shoot usually over beer we
start to talk about you know the way
things really are one of the what are
the real problems compliance is always a
word and that's compliance with a wide
variety of state and federal regulatory
agencies or without there are an army of
angry acronyms out there and they each
have a very specific agenda and I'm a
I'm not is not a judgment call on OSHA
or the EPA or the SPCA or PETA but you
know they all have their letters and
they all have their marching orders and
none of them are they
to make your life easier they're there
to make you more compliant and or maybe
more credential but really compliant
this this really played out so many
times in the in the area of safety right
I mean safety is obviously a critical
critical thing right but on dirty jobs
it was really interesting my crew and I
we we sat through so many mandatory
safety briefings so many compulsory
saving it's just done by rote everywhere
we went from factory floors to
construction sites you'd see safety
first and you know after three or four
years we started getting hurt
we never got hurt you know initially
right this time went by we began to
realize we were becoming complacent
because we were sleeping through all the
sleepy briefings that the safety first
protocols dictated so I did a special
called safety third I wasn't trying to
upset people what comes before safety
what are the two things you get to fill
in the blanks personally I would put uh
money and um I guess it's getting the
job done mm-hmm right I mean that's
right these are the fundamental things
doesn't mean Safety's really less
important right but then again saying
safety first doesn't really mean it's
the most important either it's just a
bromide you know I sat on the plane the
other day it always makes me laugh when
I look up and I see the sign that says
your safety is our priority right really
I was really hoping I'd get a pilot who
was deeply interested in getting home to
his family because he wanted to get home
to sound like or she you know my safety
is my priority his safety is priority
and you know that's just a very
different sort of way of looking at a
work dynamic but the acronyms in
question don't allow that to happen
anymore
and so the cost that comes along with it
with letting somebody else assume
responsibility for your safety
the cost is incalculable you know ask an
actuary RK EE the insurance issues the
regulation is on and on and on I don't
even know what the ultimate number is
base big let's uh push back a little bit
about I mean you know I think one sure
that can be leveled against you is the
idea well you know you're romanticizing
you're in the business of romanticizing
uh you know blue-collar work hard
physical labor which it wears people out
you know is is hard I mean it's you know
it's hard to get up you your body aches
at unlike a professional football player
you don't even have a week or an
offseason you got to get up the next day
but it's also true when you look at
earnings I'm looking at a Bureau of
Labor Statistics chart about earnings by
earnings and unemployment rates by
educational attainment if you've got a
high school degree this is in 2012 your
median weekly earnings was 652 dollars
if you've got a bachelor's degree it's a
thousand fifty six if you've got a high
school diploma the unemployment rate is
eight point three percent if you've got
a bachelor's degree it's four and a half
percent so you know why isn't college
you know like what do you say to that or
how do how do you work around that I
guess I would get another graph with
some other numbers and I'd say okay
we're a trillion dollars in debt I get
hundreds of letters a week from parents
whose beautifully educated snowflakes
are back home sleeping on their sofa you
know beautifully educated but completely
unqualified for any of the work that's
available I know what's happening more
or less right now I also know that you
know the whole notion of the inverted U
is is fascinating to me we were talking
more about Gladwell's new book which I
really like because it's the idea of
realizing that in so many areas you
don't get the extra credit you think
you'll be compensated for going the
extra mile but at some point your return
on your investment doesn't really hold
up I think that's what's happened in
education I'm not saying that what you
ought to do is go to high school and
then go straight to work that'd be as
ridiculous as saying what you ought to
do is go straight into the most
expensive school you can possibly get in
and get your degree those those two
things are equally fallacious you know
no that's why we talk about there's got
to be a component of a freelance
mentality
there has to be a new component a new
understanding of basic margins you know
the the idea that that the unemployment
rate is simply a reflection of X to few
jobs it's that doesn't make sense to me
if you have 12 million people unemployed
right now most reasonable people would
go okay so we need 12 million more jobs
except we don't it doesn't work that way
if it if it did we wouldn't have 3.9
million jobs available right now it's an
inconvenient truth to the prevailing
narrative in my opinion you know and so
I'm not against with job creation I'm
not against education not against any of
those things I'm just saying that the
statistics I've seen that are right in
front of us right now scream opportunity
the problem is the opportunities they're
screaming for have been historically
consistently and traditionally beaten
out of our own aspirational wish
fulfillment now here let me ask you this
are you are you really talking about a
crisis among men I'm in the sense that a
lot of the jobs a lot of the trades have
traditionally or historically been
dominated by men you know weren't a lot
of female carpenters except on Green
Acres I don't think there was a you know
a female carpenter you know before about
1970 so you know and when you look at
the labor force participation rate by
women from 1950 to now it just it just
goes up for men it's going down is this
really a crisis about male identity and
you know men goat would they graduate
from high school at lower rates of women
they go to college at lower rates than
women they graduate from college at
lower rates than women so is this really
a crisis about men I've no idea all
right well that was a bit that was a big
wind up for now it's a good question I
wish had a snappy answer I think that
you know there's there's probably some
obvious crossing over right more
opportunities have been made available
more women can avail themselves to them
I don't know that one necess
displaces right the other but I do
suspect there's a if not a finite or
fixed certainly a relatively
identifiable chunk of opportunity it's
being perhaps parsed out a little
differently but look I think everything
is I don't think it's as simple as that
I think I think you can look at numbers
and you can look at trends but what
about the impact of technology what
about the impact of innovation how are
those things you know affecting
available opportunities well talk a
little bit about that because Obama
President Obama a couple I guess was a
couple years ago when he talked about
you know well it's he's good to talk
about a couple of things you know when
during a stimulus he talked about
shovel-ready jobs I mean you know
everybody took that kind of literally
that he was talking about you know
building new roads or repaving them
these were these were physical labor
jobs that didn't really materialize with
the stimulus but then he also talked
about how ATMs were taking people's jobs
and it seems kind of odd because you
know when you talk about an airplane you
know airplanes displaced I don't know
railroads but then you know you need
mechanics to you know to fix the
airplanes you need guys to fuel the
airplanes you need people walking up and
down the aisle serving drinks on
airplanes so as technology the or
innovation is that the problem here it's
not we're oblem it but well you know the
displacement theories interesting you
know I first read about it in our
industry where you know the idea was the
the newspaper would displace the I know
the Telegraph for maybe was vice versa
right and then and then movies would
displace books and a TV would displace
movement and a DVD and so it doesn't
well yeah so that we have I mean you
know a good example is how radio was
supposedly killed by TV right but now we
have more TV and more radio than ever
right so it's kind of supplemental oft
yeah so but every now and then you know
every now and then you know like the
8tracks gone right it's gone yeah you
know so some sometimes things are
displaced sometimes they're just
reimagined but to your first point the
first time I heard shovel-ready jobs
as a turn of phrase I was I was in a
water tower in New York with the guys
who replace the water wouldn't wooden
water towers on top of on top of
skyscrapers and you know a guy had a had
a small TV and we were on a break and we
were watching it and everybody just
laughed at the expression shovel-ready
jobs and there was one of the guys I was
working with said you know the thing is
about all that he's going to have a lot
more success selling so shovel-ready
jobs to a country that still values the
notion of picking up a shovel and it
went right into our but the whole micro
works manifesto which is you can't
assume anymore that the thing that used
to be aspirational still is you can't
assume an existing opportunity is enough
for the opportunity to be filled it
isn't you know that that really has
fundamentally changed with respect to
technology I think you're really talking
we're really talking about efficiency
versus effectiveness which I've always
been interested in you know it's so you
have what do you mean by that I mean
that if you ask any fortune 500 company
what their views are on efficiency
they'll they'll talk very grandly and
for a long time and they'll show you
brochures and no and they'll show you
how efficient they are on dirty jobs
what I saw was was much more of an
allegiance to effectiveness you know
back to that inverted you right you you
don't need a cannon to do the the job of
a of a 22 you know it's effective you
know but the love affair with efficiency
taken too far will have a consequence
Huxley said the greatest enemy of
freedom is total anarchy but the second
greatest enemy is total efficiency right
and so we've become amazingly efficient
our PDAs our telephone there's so many
some so many examples but the more
efficient we become the less need we
have for a big workforce they're just
their opposite and there's
now wasn't that the dream of Karl Marx I
mean which is that you know after we get
to a certain point the things you know
fruit just starts falling off the tree
and you know and then we get to spend
all our time and leisure they are but
we're not there yet or it's not working
out the way that he imagined total
efficiency is total robots you know I
mean what what do you want really I mean
so again it's not a rant against
efficiency I'm not a Luddite
I'm not saying slow down I'm just saying
you ought to be aware that you know all
the charts and all the data that you
have they might be true but what is the
real context of of the world we're
living it things are happening so fast
jobs are jobs are vanishing and people
need to somehow recalibrate in this
world of hyper run efficiency and that
brings back us of that freelance thing I
mean we recognize now or it seems like
people growing up today as opposed maybe
30 years ago recognize that you know
companies like IBM and AT&T you know
Sears these these companies are not long
for the world and that the companies we
assume will guarantee you lifetime
employment are not around anymore so
part of your message is that
recalibration you always have to be
ready to spin and move into a new
direction look I think the welder is is
a really interesting example you know
because like the freelance you know he
doesn't have a Lance he has a welding
torch and and a good welder is really
it's a very artistic thing to watch it's
many many different kinds of welding
exist and the people who are good at it
or are almost savant like it used to be
called the Industrial Arts you mentioned
before how vote tech vanished from high
school well all the press that I read
about the vanishing thing from high
school was was the arts it was really
photic that went first and hardest you
know but the idea that artistry can
still exist with work is really
important and when you separate artistry
from work you get the same kind of
problem you get when you separate clean
from dirty or blue-collar from white
collar you create a gap and it's that
gap into which all kinds of things fall
you know including X
stations including opportunity and
including millions of jobs so you know I
look at I look at welding really as
maybe the best example of everything
we're talking about right now the
opportunities exist the opportunities
pay well the opportunities are wildly
underserved people don't aspire to it
and yet everything in this room requires
it you know so whether it's smooth roads
or runways or cheap electricity or
indoor plumbing or basic infrastructure
you know we used to look at the people
that provided those services as vaguely
heroic now it's not it's not that we
disparage them we don't look at them or
if we do we just don't seem right well
speaking of freelance recalibrating
dirty jobs is over what is you know what
you're doing next is it I'm going to a
series of interviews in hotel rooms
around this great land I'm talking about
the changing face of the modern-day
proletariat the bad news is there'll be
no money yes but the good news is
there's room service there's rip sir and
you can mailers TV right now look I'm
I'm living as you are in the age of
honey boo boo right not a bad thing
necessarily it's just that it's
transitioning like everything else we
were joking before the the Ducks have a
dynasty and the Amish have a mafia and a
nonfiction television right now is being
hugely impacted by writers these shows
have writers rooms right again it's okay
it's just that dirty jobs is a very
tough sell in that environment because I
never knew how dirty jobs would end I
still don't really accept that it's over
so I guess I kind of know it eventually
would end but episode by episode segment
by segment what was really for sale on
that show was uncertainty and a viewer
dug it you know people like the idea of
you know no rehearsal no scripts no
writers no ii take that today makes
people really anxious you know and so
we're seeing a much more careful
measured controlled look at something
that should be uncaring measured and
uncertain in my opinion so I've taken a
year to kind of look around and and
honestly rather than jump right into
some you know version of dirty jobs that
is more controlled I'd rather talk about
you know some of the things I learned
from doing it and and see maybe if
there's a way to you know stay relevant
in that space because really look I was
lucky I went to a community college then
I went to work then I went back to
school I got my degree but my real
education took place in reality TV
mostly in a sewer well we will leave it
there I want to thank Mike Rowe for
talking to Reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie
thank you any time if you want to swap
the Pat and a jacket the thing anytime
will go OK we could as far as long as
it's leather
I'm good with it's kind of a pleather
yes